[Music]
the LA River is so important because
it's such a landmark I just moved from
New York to LA this is my first time to
the LA River thanks for coming out you
are 2 of the 10,000 volunteers that
we're going to drought this year this is
the soft bottom section of the river
last year we pulled out a hundred and 40
tons of trash from the river otherwise
would have ended up in the Pacific Ocean
there are 2,000 storm drains that lead
into this river and so if you drop a
piece of trash a cigarette butt in the
street it ends up here oh my god I'm
looking forward to the Camino today
because I am an LA native my parents
came from Guatemala in search of a
better life so it's very personal
I'm really excited to get involved in
the community and be able to give back
to my new home I'm not afraid to get
dirty
I'm a little bit nervous about all the
germs but I'm gonna try to power through
it and not get caught up with my hang-up
let's venture out
[Music]
what's the history of the river this is
actually a natural river it hasn't
always been encased in concrete
centuries ago this is where the
indigenous peoples decided to settle
because there's a body of water here and
eventually the city grew up around it
and then there were catastrophic floods
in the 30s which is when the Army Corps
came and encased it hoping to just shunt
all of that flood water out to the ocean
as quickly as possible how long is the
river it's 51 miles long so it's all the
way from the valley to the ocean it's a
huge body of water it's all like these
little pieces in there so how do you
feel about the dirt so far the smell is
throwing me off a little yeah it's
really not terrible no air in it
yeah how many of the easy things are
produced daily in the world
what is this it's more plastic seems to
be the recurring theme of the day I
thought it was just maybe cute little
pickups in there yeah those fronds but
actually the probably goes deeper Oh
geesh what I found
[Music]
yeah these freakin straws man I'm never
gonna use a straw again until you're
confronted with it you're like okay well
how am i contributing yeah like how am I
even a part of this yeah now it's like
oh I see it I see why why they're so
weird about plastic bags I'm picking all
these things I'm like it all adds up and
it kind of like hurts my heart to see
trees intertwined with garbage because
every person drops one bag or they use a
straw or to-go cup it's like this is
what's contributing so much of this
plastic that it's everywhere similarly
if we all became a little more
conscientious of our habits yeah we
could also make that difference and make
an impact we picked up this much trash
in an hour right that's just between you
and I
now what is the greater vision for the
LA River we've been looking at ways of
getting rid of some of the concrete and
really restoring the habitat and
actually the water in the river contrary
to popular belief is much cleaner than
people realize
fishing hiking along it kayaking all of
that is safe it's not the toxic body of
water that sort of that the media has
made it see these trees as habitat
wasn't here a few decades ago this is
because of advocates like fuller we're
making progress and we hope to see more
of this sort of environment along the
river
[Music]